In theory, there are only four styles of parenting.
Authoritarian parents are controlling and
demand obedience without considering the child’s
point of view.
Permissive parents are loving, but don’t
exert any control.
There are no rules.
Authoritative parents who are firm but loving.
They encourage independence, within limits.
Neglecting parents are uninvolved and often
uninterested in their own child.
Recently a 5th style was proposed, but we
will come back to that later.
The styles range from controlling and demanding,
to complete freedom; and from cold and unresponsive
to loving and receptive.
Each, authoritative, permissive, authoritarian
and neglectful parents, have their place.
To understand what it means to grow up with
parents from each end of the spectrum, we
can imagine the lives of four children.
Sara's parents are Authoritarian.
They love their girl, but they believe that
strict rules are important to make Sara become
well behaved and fit into the society.
If Sara cries, she’s told to stop.
If she talks back, she is sent to the corner
for timeout.
If she forgets to take care of her chores
around the house, she is not allowed to play
with her toys.
Sara learns that suppressing her emotions
and following her duties is the way to get
through the day.
To get the love of her parents, and to avoid
making them upset, she becomes obedient.
However, because Sara was never allowed to
decide for herself or follow her intrinsic
interests, as an adult, she doesn't know what
she really wants.
She begins living a life that seems perfect
to her parents and society, but might leave
her unhappy on the inside.
Permissive parents , like those of Peter,
love their little boy so much that they believe
they should fulfill all his wishes, give him
full freedom and never say “no”.
Peter enjoys full control over his parents
and gets whatever he wants.
If he doesn’t want to walk, he’ll be carried.
If he wants ice-cream, ice-cream he gets.
If he wants to play games, he’ll be playing
them all night.
Peter grows up completely without borders
and does whatever he thinks is right.
He never coped with conflict and he did not
learn to control his emotions.
The fact that he always got what he wanted
made him a bad loser.
As he grows older he often acts inconsiderate
and doesn’t know his limits.
Arthur's Authoritative parents respect their
child's needs, but believe that kids need
freedom within certain limits.
Arthur can freely play, but when he’s done,
he needs to help tidy up.
He is allowed to eat ice cream, but only on
Sundays.
Screen-time is limited to 30 minutes a day.
There may be conflict, but the parents listen
to what Arthur has to say and then lay down
the rules.
However, they don’t give in, nor do they
use rewards or punishments.
Arthur learns that some things are difficult,
but his parents give him all the support he
needs to get through it.
He develops the strength to endure hardships
and to continue following his interests and
passions.
In class he bravely expresses his own opinions
in an appropriate manner.
During breaks he can show his emotions and
act freely.
As an adult he agrees to rules only after
they have been discussed and he feels like
he understands them.
Neglectful parents are usually not present
in their children's life.
Nora often feels completely alone in the world.
She experiences full freedom to do anything
she wants to and has plenty of imagination
, but she never receives any feedback, affection,
love or even attention.
Nora realizes that it doesn’t matter what
she does, because no one cares anyway.
The lack of attention, leads to a lack of
trust in herself and others.
She becomes insecurely attached, unable to
form healthy relationships and develops a
negative image of herself.
To stop feeling unworthy of love , she tries
not to feel anything at all.
In recent years, over-Involved parents, who
are present in every aspect of their child’s
life, are often referred to as the 5th style.
These parents are also known as ‘snow plows’,
removing obstacles out of their kids' path,
or 'helicopter' parents, who hover about and
micro-manage every aspect of their child's
life.
Since they won’t let their children do anything
alone, the children can’t learn to overcome
challenges by themselves.
Research infers that these children don’t
like to solve difficult problems , lack perseverance
and may even procrastinate in protest when
something requires a lot of effort.
Since most research on parenting is based
on self-reports and was done in the US and
Europe, it is not clear how strong the observed
effects will hold up in controlled observational
experiments or in other parts of the word.
The four parenting styles were first introduced
by Psychologist Diana Baumrind.
For good parenting she advised: “balance
of demandingness and responsiveness".
Add to that the wise words of Maria Montessori
to “Never help a child with a task at which
he feels he can succeed.”
and parents should probably do pretty well.
What do you think?
Should parents resort to a specific style
or should they decide what's best to do in
a given situation — as long as they don’t
neglect or abuse their child.
To download this video without background
music and learn more about the topic, visit
sproutsschools.com
For a free masterclass on attachment parenting,
see the link in the descriptions below.